this is the story of what happens when
things go wrong in your computer so what
we considered the heartbleed bug we
looked at what happens when the computer
promo exactly what we expected it to in
that case the program had been written
incorrectly so rather than returning the
right amount of data it copied a whole
load more data from the program to the
other end of the system so the
heartbleed bug is not the only thing
that can happen when the computer gauge
on that one was quite unique in that the
program appeared to be working correctly
it carried on running but we've all had
the situation where we're running a
piece of software we do something and
then suddenly it crashes and the program
quits and in those cases what's happened
is that the program has done something
which the computer can't process it's
done so in which what we class as an
exceptional thing and the computer has
thrown an exception saying hang on
I can't process it and there's various
things that can cause that so I'm going
to move to one of my older computers and
we'll just demonstrate what happens
so using here the atari falcon which was
created in the early 90s and is roughly
equivalent to the sort of power of a
machine that we get at that time the
reason i want to use this rather than
using a more modern system is that this
system in its base stage as it came
could only really run one program at a
time so we can make it crash and we can
see what happens a lot easier than if we
use a more modern system and we can then
talk about how that differs so what i've
done is i've written a program in
machine code which will basically crash
the system on command that's very very
simple we have the message that's
printed out it's a bit like this little
classic hello world program to print out
a message it then waits for a key press
to happen it calls the operating system
says get me the next key and wait until
that happens and then we have this line
here which is what crashes the system
and all this is trying to do is read
from a memory location for which there
is absolutely no memory in the system
the cpu in this system can access up to
four gigabytes worth of memory but this
machine's only got four megabytes and
about a half of Meg of ROM chip in there
as well so the memory address think that
access here does not exist in terms of
the computer's memory so when I run this
program the computer can't satisfy the
request we've asked of it because there
is no memory there
he says press any key to crash the
systems I'm going to press the spacebar
and you will see that very briefly there
two bombs appeared on screen and this
was the operating systems are telling us
that the prone had done something that
he couldn't do and so the operators
hitmen stopped the program running and
returned control to the operating system
so we can carry on now in that case the
operating system was capable of
recovering from the error it was
something that it said hang on I can
recover from this I've also mentioned
another program which is called
bad crash which is a lot more
destructive so it's very similar we
print out the same message wait for the
key press again but here rather than
just reading from one memory location
that we couldn't it takes a hollow to
the computer's memory and fills it with
zeros and I've chosen a point where the
operating system keeps is temporary
variables and so on so when I run this
it's going to totally trash a system and
we'll see what happens so I can assemble
this up and if I now run this one press
any key to crash the system I press the
spacebar again and the system's frozen
this time it hasn't even been able to
print out the error message to say
what's gone wrong that's because we've
destroyed the operating system or parts
of the operating systems data as well
and it can't get out of it I can't even
control off delete to reset it I've got
to physically hit the hardware reset
button to bring it back up so one of the
problems there is that we'd written to
memory locations that belonged to
something else in this case it was the
operating system now on a modern
computer and in fact on the CPU of this
machine as well but it wasn't used in
this operating system you have something
called a memory management unit which
can partition the memory between the
different programs and can catch those
sort of errors and say to the operating
system hang on this programs trying to
do this which you said it can't do and
so the operating system can stop it it's
not just memory access there's all sorts
of things that the program might try do
which they can't necessarily satisfy
classic example would be to divide by 0
there isn't really an answer to that
possibly you might class it as infinity
the computer can't calculate it so it
raises what's called an exception and
the operating systems are written so
that it will do something to catch that
exception so on this operating system it
would print some bombs as we saw on the
side of the screen on an old Amiga you
get a guru meditation on a Mac you'll
get a segmentation fault and you'll get
various errors on Windows in fact one
was so common in one version of Windows
that to make sure you never saw that
again
they renamed the error message that came
up so that's fine when your program
crashes the operating system can catch
it and with a bit of help from the
hardware clean up and make sure it
doesn't happen - it doesn't affect
anything else but who watches the
Watchers and what happens is a exception
thrown by the CPU by the operating
system well in that case the operating
system can't recover because it doesn't
know the correct state it's meant to be
in and so it panics and so we get on our
screen if we're using Linux or a magnet
what's called a kernel panic because the
copper system can't continue on Windows
it's the infamous blue screen of death
and generally it'll give you some
information that it's useful to a
developer to see what's going wrong with
your operating system you have to reset
the Machine and hopefully it'll start up
again sometimes you're a little more
unfortunate and you have to replace the
whole machine it's worth bearing in mind
that not all the exceptions that an
operating system has to deal with are
necessarily bad when you hit a key on
the keyboard move your mouse or gets a
network packet on your network that's
something exceptional which the
operating system has to deal with but
it's able to process that and then carry
on doing whatever it was doing
beforehand
occasionally you'll get something
happening which just completely destroys
the operators ability to continue now if
you need to understand why that might
happen if you've got a bug in your code
like we saw with heartbleed but
sometimes you'll be sitting using
machine and it's been fine for years
weeks months whatever it is and suddenly
you'll get a kernel panic and it's
helpful then to think about what might
have changed perhaps if you're a Linux
or BSD freak and you're regularly
compiling your kernel then you may have
misconfigured it and so you put in a new
kernel and suddenly you've started up
and it kernel panics if you've just
installed a new piece of hardware it's
possible the drivers for that at the
hardware itself is incompatible or
grating with the system and causing to
parts of your operating system to not
work as well together but occasionally
just for no reason at all
all your computer will start Colonel
panicking and you won't necessarily know
what causes it well the common cause is
perhaps the memory if the memory starts
to fail but occasionally even if the
memory is working correctly there may
still be a mistake in the memory if a
cosmic ray hits the actual memory cell
then it can flip the bit from a zero to
a one or a one to a zero this is more
likely to happen if you're higher up so
people in Colorado for example are more
likely to suffer from this on the
computer systems or a satellite in space
isn't likely to have problems like this
it's not what you can do to prevent this
cosmic rays going to hit it if it's
going to hit it you can shield it about
with a bit of metal but you could also
use memory that actually can detect that
the narrows happen so one of the things
you see is error correcting memory or
ECC memory but even so if you still get
to the point where the operating system
gets corrupted and can't continues
you'll expect and then it's just going
to have to kernel panic
when a and B transmit they have to
arrange that when their packets arrive
at the base station that they arrive
this one in this time slot and this one
in this time slot I have attached the
square of side to directed to the south
as it were and the two boxes outside one